so the second largest bank failure in
U.S history happened at 4 a.m clearly
they're trying to do it well they want
to do it before the markets opened and
they did it kind of out of sight of
everybody and I'm surprised it's not
getting more attention First Republic
Bank was seized by the U.S government
and then sold off to JP Morgan with I
think it was 50 billion dollars in
Federal Financing which is basically
like y'all are bailing them out again as
much as Biden's insisting you're not so
uh look I don't know what to tell you
man there's some economists saying the
dollar is doomed I'm not here to give
you any Financial advice but I think
when you've had three of the largest
banking failures in U.S history within
the span of a couple months
I don't know maybe you should go seek
some Financial advice not for me but I
know I'm gonna be making some moves
because I'm kind of worried what they're
saying is that people panicked over
First Republic pulled their money out
many of them actually went to JP Morgan
but my fear now is I'm not Economist but
if JP Morgan's absorbing this this dying
Bank isn't that just going to get people
scared